>> Tucker: HOW TERRIFIED IS
JOE BIDEN OF THE RADICALS IN HIS
PARTY?
WELL, HERE’S ONE MEASURE.
HE’S SO TERRIFIED THAT HE JUST
MADE ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
THE HEAD OF HIS GLOBAL WARMING
TASK FORCE.
SHE IS THE WOMAN WHO BLAMES
HURRICANE DEATHS ON RACISM.
>> DO WE SEE LARGELY THAT IT’S
THE GLOBAL COMMUNITIES IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT MAY
BEARING THE BRUNT OF THE INITIAL
HAVOC FROM CLIMATE CHANGE?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PRODUCING
CLIMATE CHANGE, THE FOLKS THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LARGEST
AMOUNT OF COMMISSIONS OR
COMMUNITIES OR CORPORATIONS,
THEY TEND TO BE PREDOMINANTLY
WHITE, CORRECT?
>> YES, AND EVERY STUDY BACKS
THAT UP.
>> Tucker: SO NOT REALLY A
SCIENCE PERSON, NOW SHE IS
RUNNING GLOBAL WARMING FOR
JOE BIDEN.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
DANA PERINO HAS BEEN WATCHING,
SHE HOSTS THE DAILY BRIEFING
WITH DANA PERINO, ALWAYS
DELIGHTED TO HAVE HER.
SO MY THEORY, KNOCK IT DOWN IF
YOU LIKE, IS THAT BIDEN ISN’T
WEDDED TO DEEP BELIEFS AND HE IS
AT THIS POINT A VESSEL OR SOME
OF THE MORE RADICAL PEOPLE IN
HIS PARTY, DO YOU THINK THAT’S
RIGHT?
>> WELL, IT CERTAINLY GIVES THAT
APPEARANCE, RIGHT?
SO IF YOU SHOW ME A CANDIDATE
THAT IS STILL WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR BASE AT THIS POINT IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION, I’LL SHOW YOU
SOMEBODY WHO IS VERY UNSTEADY AS
A CANDIDATE.
I CAN’T TELL YOU HOW HAPPY
REPUBLICANS WERE YESTERDAY WHEN
THEY FOUND OUT THAT AOC IS GOING
TO BE IN CHARGE OF ENERGY POLICY
AND CLIMATE POLICY FOR THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN, BECAUSE BIDEN IS
ACTUALLY COURTING VOTERS THAT
ALREADY WERE GOING TO VOTE FOR
HIM.
BUT HE’S TURNING OFF THE VOTERS
WHO MAY HAVE VOTED FOR HIM.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, AOC TURNS OFF
PEOPLE IN THE SUBURBS LIKE IN
THE DISTRICT AT THE REPUBLICAN
SPLIT LAST NIGHT IN CALIFORNIA.
HOW ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA WHO RELY ON
FRACKING JOBS?
THEY SAID THEY WANT TO KILL THAT
THROUGH THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
AND THE JUSTICE THAT SHE’S A
PART OF, THEY LOST THAT SEAT
LAST NIGHT, THEY LOST IN
WISCONSIN.
ILHAN OMAR HAS HAD A REALLY
TOUGH RACE.
NOBODY’S ACTUALLY LISTENING TO
THE AOC AND OMAR BECAUSE THEY
ARE DWINDLING IN POWER BUT
JOE BIDEN KEEPS GIVING THEM NEW
LIFE.
IT’S KIND OF BAFFLING.
>> Tucker: IT’S NOT BAFFLING
ONCE YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU
JUST SAID, WHICH IS THIS IS WHAT
WEAK CANDIDATES DO, THEY PANDER
TO THE FRINGES BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN’T SHORED THEM UP.
>> WRITES, AND SO I THINK THAT
IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA, THAT’S GOING TO BE
A BATTLEGROUND.
IF THERE’S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
YOU ALREADY HAVE PEOPLE IN A
TOUGH SPOT WHEN IT COMES TO
UNEMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
BUT THE ENERGY JOBS, THEY ARE IN
PARTICULAR DANGER OF MAYBE NOT
EVEN COMING BACK IF THEY CAN’T
GET BACK QUICKLY AND IF THEY
THINK THAT JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO
BRING ON AOC AS A CLIMATE
ADVISOR, THEN GAME OVER, I THINK
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP PROBABLY AT
LEAST BE ABLE TO WIN BACK THOSE
VOTERS QUITE HANDILY IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Tucker: THAT’S SUCH A SMART
POINT AND AS YOU NOTED, HE
DOESN’T REALLY NEED TO DO THIS,
BUT HE’S DOING IT ANYWAY, WHICH
TELLS YOU SOMETHING PRETTY WEIRD
WEIRD.
>> IT’S HURTING HIM.
HE WAS ABLE TO ACTUALLY WIN THIS
NOMINATION BY KNOCKING THEM DOWN
AND NOW HE’S EMBRACING THEM.
IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
>> Tucker: IT’S VERY STRANGE.
BUT I THINK HE’S A VESSEL FOR
OTHERS, AND THAT’S MAYBE THE
WORST THING.